herzlich willkommen wir haben eine
zusätzliche Sondersendung ins Programm
genommen um sie über die Situation und
Israel in und in den
Palästinensergebieten zu informieren in
den kommenden 45 Minuten analysieren wir
die aktuelle Situation und fragen wie
groß die Gefahr ist dass die Lage
eskaliert auch die ganze Nacht über
hielten die Kampfhandlungen an
gegenseitiger Raketenbeschuss und nach
wie vor sind wohl noch palästinensische
Kämpfer in Israel
aktiv es beginnt am frühen Morgen die
radikale Hamas die den Gazastreifen
regiert feuert in einem
Überraschungsangriff tausende Raketen
auf Israel zu viele in zu kurzer Zeit
das Raketenabwehrsystem irondome kann
sie nicht alle
abfangen es war eine massive Explosion
ich habe ein Kind schreien hören ich
weiß auch nicht wir leben in einer
Realität die so surreal ist
ein Horrorszenario das Israels
Bevölkerung seit Jahren kennt immer
wieder kommt es zu militärischen
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen Hamas und
Israel doch dann geschieht zeitgleich
was so noch nie passiert ist zahlreiche
bewaffnete Kämpfer der Hamas dringen aus
dem eigentlich durch eine Sperranlage
streng abgeriegelten und überwachten
Gazastreifen auf israelischen Boden vor
handyvos von israelischen Bürgern zeigen
wie sie sich Schusswechsel mit Polizei
und Armee liefern sie dringen Häuser ein
töten Zivilisten auf der Straße Bilder
zum Teil zu grausam als dass wir sie
hier zeigen könnten Israels prämier
Benjamin Netanyahu ruft das
Sicherheitskabinett zusammen und den
Kriegszustand
aus seit heute morgen ist der Staat
Israel im Krieg unser erstes Ziel ist es
die feindlichen Kräfte auf unserem Boden
zu eliminieren und Sicherheit in den
Ortschaften
wiederherzustellen Israels
Militärführung beruft unterdessen
ztausende Reservisten ein die Armee
beginnt Luftangriff auf den Gazastreifen
zu fliegen von dort melden
palästinensische Behörden rund 200 Tote
in einer seltenen propagandaansprache
wendet sich der Militärchef der Hamas an
die
Öffentlichkeit wir haben beschlossen den
israelischen Verbrechen mit Gottes Hilfe
ein Ende zu setzen damit der Feind
begreift dass die Zeit in der er Unheil
anrichten kann ohne zur Rechenschaft
gezogen zu werden vorbei ist die
Menschen in Gaza flüchten derweil vor
den Bomben aber es gibt auch
Unterstützung für die hamasführung
nein nein ich habe keine Angst ruft
diese Frau dem Reporter zu wir werden
alle sterben irgendwann aber vorher
hoffentlich
Siegen unterdessen setzt sich der
Albtraum für die israelische Bevölkerung
fort wie Schlachtfelder sehen einige
israelische Ortschaften aus mehr als 100
Tote zählen Sie bis jetzt verzweifelt
die Überlebenden immer mehr Videos
zeigen wie lebende und getötete
israelische Bürger in den Gazastreifen
verschleppt werden heute torora ein
jüdischer Feiertag der mit einem
unerwarteten Angriff startet und dann
Tod und Zerstörung bringt wie vor 50
Jahren als der jomkipur Krieg anfing und
es ist nicht vorbei mehrere hundert
Kämpfer der Hamas sollen noch auf
israelischem Boden
sein in Israel begrüße ich jetzt den CDF
Korrespondenten Michael bewerunge guten
Tag nach
telaviv Herr bberunge wie ist die
aktuelle Situation in Israel und in Gaza
also noch immer halten einzelne Gefechte
an würde ich sagen es gibt keine
geiselnamen mehr in den Dörfern auf
israelischenem Boden vor dem
Gazastreifen aber es gibt anscheinend
noch immer marodierende Kämpfer er gegen
Mittag hat man auf der Autobahn zwischen
astot und askelon einen Wagen
aufgegriffen mit vier hamaskämpfern sie
gestellt und getötet das ist schon 30 km
quasi nördlich des gasastreifens also
deutlich im Norden auch gestern gab es
den ganzen Tag immer wieder
Straßensperren Richtung Norden wir
beobachtet haben weil eben die Sorge
groß ist dass masskämpfer noch weiter
ins Land vordringen könnten ansonsten
gehen die Truppen jetzt hier quasi von
Haus zu Haus so muss man sich das
wirklich vorstellen in jedem einzelnen
Dorf und überprüfen ob es noch irgendwo
versteckte hamasskämpfer gibt bevor Sie
dieses Gebiet freigeben das ist noch
lange nicht der Fall ich habe heute
Mittag mit m einem IDF mit einem
Armeesprecher gesprochen und der sagte
mir noch ist es nicht möglich
dorthinzugehen das ist immer noch eine
Kampfzone und auch sterot ist noch nicht
freigegeben was wissen wir über die
Opfer wie viel Tote und wie viel
verletzte hat es nach bisherigem Stand
auf beiden Seiten
gegeben
mm also nach äh äh jüngst Erzählung sind
es über
350 Tote auf israelischer Seite da
kommen aber noch noch sehr sehr viel
dazu es gibt über 1900 verletzte viele
von denen sind in kritischem Zustand äh
auf palästinensischer Seite gibt es über
300 Tote und auch ähnlich viele 1800
verletzte weil die Israelis eben auch
massiv den Gazastreifen momentan
bombardieren jetzt haben sie ja gesagt
dass die geiselnamen auf israelischem
Gebiet beendet sind aber es ist der Herr
Mass ja offensichtlich gelungen Geiseln
nach Gaza zu verschleppen wissen wir um
wie viele Geiseln es sich handelt und
wie Israel darauf reagieren
will mittlerweile
gibt es ein ziemlich genaue Schätzung
nämlich an die 100 hat die israelische
Botschaft in Washington herausgelassen
100 Soldaten und Zivilisten die entführt
worden sind es melden sich immer mehr
Familien die sagen ich konnte z.B
teilweise das Handy von meiner Frau von
meiner Tochter bis nach Junis
zurückverfolgen das ist im Süden des
Gazastreifens andere haben ihre
Angehörigen ihre Kinder auf Videos der
Hamas wieder entdeckt ist inzwischen
auch hier ein
vermisstenzentrum in Tel Aviv
eingerichtet worden also es gibt eine
beträchtliche Zahl und das ist natürlich
ein Riesenproblem für alles das was
Israel noch vorhat militärisch gegen die
Hamas zu unternehmen jetzt soll Ägypten
als Vermittler eing geschaltet werden
stimmt das und was würde das bedeuten
äh ohne dass ich es genau weiß würde ich
sagen das stimmt weil Ägypten
traditionell immer der hauptvermittler
in Konflikten zwischen der Hamas und
Israel ist ich wage allerdings zu
bezweifeln dass es einen ernsthaften
Vermittlungsversuch geben kann die
Strategie
von Benjamin terau ist völlig klar er
hat das gesagt das sind zwei Dinge
erstens er will Rache üben deswegen wird
jetzt ein Luft Angriff nach dem anderen
geflogen vor allem natürlich gegen
militärische Ziele aber das hat immer
auch zivile Opfer zieht das nach sich
das zweites hat gesagt er will nie
wieder zu einer solchen Situation kommen
wo ein solcher Angriff möglich ist das
bedeutet es kann nur einen massiven
Bodenangriff geben der Generalstabschef
hat heute verkündet er lässt mehrere
hunderttaus Reservisten einberufen für
eine mögliche Bodenoffensive und diese
Bodenoffensive jetzt komme ich zu
Ägypten hätte natürlich gerade für den
Nachbarn extreme folgen weil sich dann
ein gigantischer Flüchtlingsstrom von
herttausenden aus dem Gazastreifen
wahrscheinlich Richtung Ägypten bewegen
würde und das würde auch in Ägypten eine
riesenkrise werden allein schon weil man
die muslimischen Extremisten auch dort
nicht im Lande haben will also eine
große Krise bahnt sich hier an und
Ägypten hat natürlich ein interess zu
vermitteln aber bei der Entschlossenheit
die man bei der israelischen Regierung
sieht ist nicht davon aus auszugehen
dass sie
von ihrem Plan Rache und klare
Bedingungen schaffen dass das nicht
wieder passiert dass sie davon abgehen
das war Michael beverunge live aus Tel
Aviv herzlichen Dank der israelische
Premier netano hat sich in der Nacht an
die israelische Bevölkerung gewandt und
sie auf einen langen Krieg eingeschworen
wörtlich wir werden alle Orte an denen
die Hamas organisiert ist und sich
versteckt in trümmerinsel
bitte hab Erinnerung das hat mit dem
Helden des stat Israels zu tun also
jehudaus
makabeus D König David und andere Helden
des Staates Israel sie kämpfen für das
Haus von uns alle für die Zukunft unser
von unseren unseres Landes wir sindind
alle bei euch wir lieben euch
Staatsbürger und auch für die
Rettungskräften sind wir sehr dankbar
die heute alles mitgemacht haben in
verschiedenen Orten im Lande das Volk
Israel ja
salutiert für eure Kräfte und das was
sie alles macht ich habe vor einigen
Stunden gesprochen mit Präsidenten Biden
und mit anderen Führer der verschiedenen
Länder dies der Welt um damit wir eine
freie Hand haben werden um diesen Krieg
weiterzu führen ich bedanke mich bei dem
französischen
Präsidenten Großbritannien
Ministerpräsidenten auch Präsident
beiden und ich wende an Euch
alle Staatsbürger Israel wir sind
zusammen in diesem Krieg das wird dauern
das wird eine harte Krieg sein es wird
noch lange dauern wir werden noch
schwierige Tagen haben aber eine Sache
kann ich Ihnen versprechen mit Gottes
Hilfe mit unseren gemeinsamen
Kräften unser Glaube an Israel werden
wir
gewinnen zugeschaltet aus Israel begrüße
ich jetzt den deutsch-israelischen
Schriftsteller Arie schalikar herzlich
willkommen Herr schalikar zunächst zu
Ihrer Person bis gestern waren sie
ehemaliger Armeesprecher der
israelischen Streitkräfte jetzt wurden
sie wieder
eingezogen ja richtig seit heute früh
bin ich
eingezogen in form wie man jetzt sehen
kann und vertrete die israelische Armee
offiziell als Sprecher wieder was können
Sie uns über die Situation in Israel und
Gaza
Berichten nach wie vor gibt es
Kriegshandlung auch auf israelischem
Territorium es gibt einige Ortschaften
in Israel selbst eine Handvoll die immer
noch von terroristischen Gruppierungen
von
Terrorkommandos in Angst und Schrecken
versetzt werden äh und die israelischen
Sicherheitskräfte versuchen dort jetzt
natürlich für Ordnung zu sorgen und
Stabilität wieder reinzubringen die
Terroristen zu neutralisieren hinzu
kommt natürlich dass die israelische
Luftwaffe seit gestern auch im
Gazastreifen gezielt
terrorinfrastrukturziele angreift der
Hamas aber auch des islamischen dihad um
auch
die Terroristen zu bekämpfen gibt es
schon eine Erklärung dafür warum die
israelischen Streitkräfte die gesamte
israelische Gesellschaft von diesem
Angriff so überrascht
wurde es wird wenn es irgendwann dann
mal wieder zur Ruhe kommen sollte und es
wird irgendwann der Tag kommen wird das
alles gründlich untersucht werden äh
hier muss man sich hinsetzen und
Hausaufgaben machen und die Lektion aus
dieser Situation von gestern die ja noch
nicht vorüber ist äh lernen äh wir haben
es hier mit äh tödlichen terrorb
Bewegungen zu tun die an unseren Grenzen
sitzen 1 mer hinter dem Sicherheitszaun
ab im Gazastreifen oder im Libanon
sitzen terrorbewegung die Tag ein Tag
aus eigentlich nichts anderes planen als
Juden anzugreifen und zu ermorden und
wie wir sehen auch zu entführen und da
dürfen wir eigentlich niemals
äh ich sag jetzt mal nicht wachsam sein
sondern wir müssen ständig auf der Hut
sein vor diesen bösen Menschen und das
ist gestern über uns hineingetroffen und
wir müssen gucken dass wir jetzt
gegen diese Terroristen vorgehen und
wieder Ordnung einbringen ja premier
Netanyahu hat eine sehr harte Reaktion
angekündigt eine Zerstörung der Hamas
und ihrer Basis was bedeutet
das das bedeutet in erster Linie dass äh
dass die israelische Politik und das
Militär ist ziemlich ernst meinen wenn
wir sagen dass die Hamas und auch der
islamische dihad nächsten Tagen Wochen
Monaten äh äh auf der Hut sein sollte äh
dass sie nie wieder so auf dem Beinen
stehen werden wie sie es bis vorgestern
oder bis gestern getan haben äh dieser
diese Terrororganisation die maßgeblich
natürlich auch von den mullers im Iran
unterstützt werden und auch teilweise
mit Finanzspritzen aus dem Westen
überhaupt imstande sind das zu machen
was sie jetzt gerade machen äh müssen
ein für alle Male
äh äh
bekämpft werden damit derartige
Situation wie wir sie gestern erlebt
haben und heute nach wie vor erleben
dass derartige Situation nie wieder
vorkommt ist eine Invasion eine
Besetzung des Gazastreifens eine Option
die auf dem Tisch
ist viele Optionen sind derzeit auf dem
Tisch
weil man operativ natürlich gucken muss
wie man vorgehen muss einerseits
natürlich die Terroristen
die
terrorinfrastruktur terrortunnel
Waffenlager und so weiter anzugreifen
gleichzeitig jedoch äh
Kollateralschäden so äh minimal wie
möglich hält äh und gleichzeitig den
Sicherheitszaun zum Gazastreifen
natürlich wieder in Takt bringt während
wir jetzt in diesen Stunden werden wir
dieses Gespräch führen auch die
Terrorzellen der der Hamas auf
israelischen Territorium nach wie vor
bekämpfen es wurde heute morgen gemeldet
dass es auch Angriffe Raketenangriffe
der hisbolla aus dem Libanon auf den
Norden Israels gegeben hat was können
Sie uns dazu
sagen es gab in den Morgenstunden einen
mörserangriff aus dem Libanon die
israelische Armee hat darauf reagiert
isbolla hat daraufhin die Verantwortung
übernommen bis jetzt ist es nach wie vor
still
das kann sich natürlich ändern israel
hat über die verschiedensten Kanäle der
hisbolla klar gemacht dass ein Abenteuer
wie sie es 2006 gewagt haben sich nicht
für Sie lohnen wird nasrala Chef der
Terrororganisation Hisbollah lebt seit
2006 in einem Bunker weil er weiß wie
die israelische Armie reagieren wird
falls die hisbolla die Waffen nicht
stillhalten sollte herzlichen Dank das
war der Sprecher der israelischen Armee
Arie schalika herzlichen
Dank seit über 16 Jahren seit ihrem
Wahlsieg 2006 und ihrer kompletten
Machtübernahme 2007 herrscht die Hamas
über den gazaastreifen wer ist diese
Organisation der es gelang Israel mit
den gestrigen Angriffen zu überraschen
worauf basiert ihre Stärke und wer
unterstützt die
Hamas der Überraschungsangriff der
radikalislamischen Hamas trifft Israel
in einem Moment der Schwäche das Land
tief gespalten über die hochumstrittene
Justizreform in die samstäglichen
Massenproteste gegen die gefürchtete
aushölung der Demokratie hatten sich
auch Reservisten des israelischen
Militärs eingereiht und den Dienst
verweigert für die Hamas wohl ein
Zeichen dass der Erzfeind verwundbar
scheint außerdem haben sich im von
Israel besetzten Westjordanland die
Kämpfe rund um israelische
Militäroperationen gegen militante
Palästinenser seit Monaten zugespitzt
mit immer mehr Toten vor ein paar Tagen
etwa in tulkarem immer wieder greifen
Palästinenser israelische Soldaten und
Siedler an und radikale Siedler gehen zu
brutal gegen Palästinenser vor wie bei
ihren Attacken auf Palästinenser in der
arabischen Stadt havara das israelische
Militär habe sich vor allem auf diese
Brennpunkte konzentriert und zu wenig
auf den Gazastreifen so kritisieren es
Beobachter nachdem Israel dort im
Grenzgebiet zu Gaza und kalt von
hamasangreifern erwischt
wurde traumatische Erinnerungen werden
wach genau vor
Jahren wurde Israel ebenfalls überrascht
als die arabischen Feinde Angriffen und
Israel zunächst ohnmächtig in die Enge
gedrängt worden
war der Militärchef der Hamas Mohammed
div begründet den Angriff auch mit
Aggressionen gegen die alxa Moschee in
Jerusalem eines der höchsten Heiligtümer
des Islam dass ich dort auf dem
Tempelberg wo einst der jüdische Tempel
stand auch Juden versammeln sieht die
Hamas als Provokation kommt es hier zu
Ausschreitungen wird die Lage
explosiv Israels rechtsextremer
Sicherheitsminister ben hat Hieron nicht
allzu langer Zeit wieder Öl ins Feuer
gegossen die Polizei macht deutlich wer
hier das Sagen hat alle Drohungen der
Hamas helfen nicht Jerusalem und Israel
sind unser
Land als Verteidigung von al-aksa sieht
die Hamas die jetzigen Angriffe und ruft
alle islamischen Verbündeten auf sich an
ihrem Kampf zu beteiligen im Iran dem
Erzfeind Israels Parlamentarier rufen
Palästina wird siegen Israel wird
zerstört der Iran gilt als Unterstützer
radikaler Kräfte im Gazastreifen und in
Israels Nachbarland Libanon dort an der
Grenze zu Israels Norden steht die
iranisch gesteuerte Hisbollah Miliz
bereit wird sich die Hisbollah an den
kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen
beteiligen fragt man sich in Israel ihr
Arsenal von geschätzt mehr als 100.000
Raketen wäre bei weitem gefährlicher als
die Waffen der
Hamas im Studio begrüße jetzt
Professor Politikwissenschaftler an der
Universität Erlangen Nürnberg hallo
bleiben wir zunächst mal bei der Hamas
die Hamas wird von Deutschland als
Terrororganisation
äh eingeordnet ist diese Einordnung
richtig oder ist das auch eine legitime
Vertretung der Palästinenser die sich
nicht anders zu helfen wissen nein also
anerkannt wird sie nicht als legitime
Vertretung wird das alvater Regime
angesehen der Führung von Abbas und äh
es ist ja auch bekannt dass die
Palästinenser selbst untereinander
erheblich zerstritten sind eben diese
beiden Lager und ähm dass die Einstufung
als Terrororganisation erfolgt die im
Übrigen nicht nur die Bundesregierung
teilt sondern die Europäische Union
offiziell insgesamt auch die Vereinigten
Staaten die westliche Welt insgesamt
aber auch durchaus darüber hinaus auch
einige andere Staaten das hat auch was
damit zu tun dass diese Organisation
kein he daraus macht dass ihr das
erklärte Ziel ist die Vernichtung der
Existenz Israels so warum hat die Hamas
ihren Angriff gerade jetzt gestartet ja
wir haben es ja eben den Bericht schon
so ein bisschen gehört der Zeitpunkt
scheint offensichtlich günstig
anderserseits glaube ich ist auch so ein
Stück weit der Verzweiflung geschuldet
natürlich hat das was damit zu tun dass
D die Lage zugespitzt hat nicht nur dort
in dem nach wie vor blockierten
gazerastreifen sondern wie wir eben auch
gehört haben in wjordanland wir sehen
dass Israel und das war mit Sicherheit
ein Motiv im Moment in einer sehr sehr
kritischen Situation sich befindet
obwohl man das sehr wahrscheinlich
unterschätzt hat denn Israel rückt in so
einer Situation glaube ich eher gestärkt
zusammen das heißt die Oppositionskräfte
haben ja auch schon angedeutet also wenn
die Sicherheit Israels auf dem Spiel
steht dann kennt man kein Pardon und
dann rückt man eben zusammen
und dann sind darüber hinaus natürlich
auch die das ein Motiv mit Sicherheit
auch die veränderte geopolitische
Ausgangssituation in der Region
insgesamt die arabische Welt rückt
zunehmend näher an Israel Saudiarabien
insbesondere die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate viele andere auch Katar ist die
rümliche Ausnahme diesbezüglich versucht
D so ein bisschen hier neutral zu
verhalten aber hier brückelt die
Unterstützung weg und das einzige
Vehikel der einzige Adressat den man
eigentlich noch hat ist weniger sind
weniger die Regime von denen ich nicht
annehme dass sie große Unterstützung
zeigen werden ab abgesehen von Iran das
haben wir gehört sondern ist die
arabische Gesellschaft die insgesamt
natürlich mehrheitlich noch an der für
die palästinensische Sache eintritt aber
bei den Regimen dringt das im Grunde
genommen nicht durch ist diese
Annäherung zwischen Israel und den
Golfstaaten zwischen Israel und
Saudi-Arabien jetzt aufs erste gestoppt
oder kann dieser Prozess weitergehen ich
glaube der wird weitergehen ich meine
das muss man abwarten solange dass
derartig der Konflikt jetzt schwäht und
solange er anhält in der Form werden
alle sich sehr vorsichtig und bedeckt
halten das ist vollkommen klar aber ich
glaube nicht dass es deswegen eine
Abkehr davon geben wird
und das ist ja auch das was dazu
beiträgt dass eben Iran mit Sicherheit
von außen als derjenige welche der
förder und Unterstützer alles daran
setzen wird
diesen Keil auch über die Hamas
vielleicht eventuell zwischen die
arabische Welt zwischen die Golfstaaten
vor allen Dingen jetzt allen voran und
Israel zu treiben daran kannst kein
Zweifel geben wie groß ist die Gefahr
einer Eskalation dass es zum Konflikt an
der Nordgrenze zu Libanon und Syrien
kommt dass es vor allem zu einem
Konflikt direkten Konflikt zwischen
Israel und dem Iran kommt ich glaube
nicht dass es zu einem solchen
Zweifrontenkrieg jetzt kommen wird ich
glaube nicht dass wir Ähnliches erleben
werden aus dem Norden ich halte diese
Aktion will ich sagen für eine einmalige
aber eher für eine
Solidaritätsaktion mit der Hamas
weil das hochbrisant ist für den Libanon
der im Moment natürlich auch ohnehin
einer extrem labilen und schwierigen
Situation sich befindet Ägypten wird ein
großes Interesse daran haben äh dass
dieser Konflikt auch nicht und Syrien
gleichermaßen dass der sich überschwabt
und überschlägt auf auf ein weiteres
also auch auf den libanesischen Staat
und die Grenzregion äh das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen es wird aber sehr stark
davon abhängen in der Tat wie stark Iran
das
hinter den Kulissen forciert aber auch
da gehe ich davon aus dass keine jetzt
im Moment eine Konfrontation sucht die
dann das knüpft dann ihre zweite Frage
an tatsächlich dazu führt dass wir eben
noch weitere involvierte Kriegsparteien
haben werden das ist das vielleicht auch
die Tragik und das Dilemma der Hamas
insofern sehe ich diese Tat trotz allem
und diesen heutigen und gestrigen Tag
natürlich auch als eine Art
Verzweiflungstat einmal mehr die wohl
orchestriert und vorbereitet war der
herass an die natürlich weiß um ihre
ausweglose Situation wir unterhalten uns
gleich weiter wollen jetzt kurz einen
Blick auf die USA wer Israel ist auf die
Unterstützung der USA angewiesen und in
den letzten Monaten war das Verhältnis
zwischen beiden Regierungen mehr als
angespannt die Regierung beiden
kritisierte ganz offen die Politik der
Regierung Netanyahu vor allem die
geplante Justizreform in einer
Stellungnahme heute Nacht stellte sich
jetzt US-Präsident beiden ganz eindeutig
an die Seite
Israels heute ist Israel angegriffen
worden von einer Terrororganisation der
Hamas diesem tragischen Augenblick
möchte ich der Welt folgendes sagen die
Vereinigten Staaten stehen auf Seiten
Israels wir werden nie die Unterstützung
verweigern die Bürger brauchen
Unterstützung damit sie ihre Ziele
erreichen können die Welt hat schlimme
Bilder gesehen tausende von Raketen sind
in Stunden abgeschossen worden und
sind auf Städte
niedergeregnet wir sind nicht nur
israelische Soldaten getötet worden
sondern auch viele Zivilisten auf den
Straßen zu Hause unschuldige Menschen
sind ermordet oder verletzt worden ganze
Familien sind von der Hamas als Geiseln
genommen worden das ist einer der
heiligsten Tage im jüdischen Kalender
gewesen an dem der Angriff erfolgt
ist ich habe heute morgen Israel
versichert dass die USA auf der Seite
des Staates Israel stehen israel hat das
Recht sich und sein Volk zu verteidigen
Punkt Ausrufezeichen es gibt nie eine
Rechtfertigung für solche Angriffe meine
Administration
unterstützt ohne zu zögern Israel in
jeder Hinsicht und ich will das ganz
klar sagen dies ist nicht der Augenblick
wo irgendjemand diese Angriffe zum
eigenen Vorteil ausnutzen kann die Welt
schaut zu
ich bin auch mit dem König von Jordanien
in Kontakt gewesen habe mit
Kongressabgeordneten gesprochen mit
meinen sicherheitsmitarbeitern und deren
israelischen
Entsprechungen Diplomaten haben
miteinander geredet es muss dafür
gesorgt werden dass Israel das bekommt
was es braucht ich habe auch mein Team
angewiesen ständige Kontakte in der
Region zu pflegen auch mit Ägypten der
Türkei Katar
Saudi-Arabien Oman und anderen und auch
den palästinensischen Partnern das ist
eine auch menschlich ganz schlimme
Tragödie sehr sehr viele Menschen haben
erleben müssen dass hier Familien
auseinander gerissen worden sind und ich
denke an die Familien die von dieser
Gewalt betroffen sind wir trauern mit
denen die ihre geliebten Angehörigen
verloren
haben wir hoffen auf die baldige
Genesung vieler der Verwundeten wir sind
im
Kontakt mit Premierminister nanaho im
Zuge der weiteren Entwicklung und das
muss ganz klar sein die Vereinigten
Staaten stehen auf Seiten des Staates
Israel die USA waren die erste
Nation die
Israel anerkannt hat einige Minuten nach
der Gründung des Staates
danke nach wie vor bei uns ist Professor
Stefan fröhlich klar Prof natürlich die
Hamas ist eindeutig der Angreifer
trotzdem die Frage was hat die Regierung
netano zur Eskalation beigetragen durch
ihre aggressive Siedlungspolitik die
Abriegelung des
Gazastreifens z.B erhebliches daran
gibt's kein Zweifel und es ist ja auch
so dass das durchaus auch von der
internationalen Staatenwelt aus dem
westlichen Lager heraus wenn ich das
jetzt so formulieren darf dass es diese
Kritik immer wieder gegeben hat
unverholen gerade beiden wir haben ih
eben gehört ähm hat sich mehrfach
diesbezüglich sehr sehr kritisch
geäußert und wir tun das hier aus der
Europäischen Union heraus wir wissen auf
der anderen Seite alle gerade in Europa
gerade hier zulande Israel ist
staatsreson und das gilt imum auch für
die
Vereinigten Staaten insofern wenn die
hammas tatsächlich irgendwie so etwas
wie ein strategisches Kalkül dahinter
hatte dann kann das mit Sicherheit nicht
gewesen sein dass dadurch vielleicht
irgendwie äh man Hoffnung haben durfte
dass sich der Westen hier vielleicht im
besten Fall neutral verhalten würde oder
ruhig halten würde äh damit konnte man
schlicht und einfach nicht rechnen
insofern
ähm ja dies dieser dieser Angriff wird
klar und deutlich verurteilt er ist
vökerrechtswidrig in jeder Hinsicht
zumal aufgrund der Qualität es geht ja
diesmal nicht nur um Raketen abschießen
sondern man ist in das Land eingedrungen
und
so ist es eben auch kommuniziert worden
und das hat man glaube ich wenn es denn
wirklich ein Kalkül war kolossal
unterschätzt vor diesem Angriff war die
israelische Gesellschaft tief gespalten
jetzt gibt es Überlegungen angesichts
dieser existenziellen Bedrohung Israels
eine Art Notstands eine
Einheitsregierung zu bilden da hören wir
uns zunächst mal den Oppositionsführer
oder einen der Oppositionsführer jahir
lapit
an Bürger
israelsunchst möchte ich von hier mein
Bein schicken an die en der
Getöteten und auch eine Verstärkung für
alle Streitkräfte die ihre Arbeit gerade
machenck auch eine starke Verstärkung
für alle Bewohner des Süden im Süden des
Landes ich rufe allen dass sie das alles
tun müssen was unser Verteidigungssystem
hier befehlt es ist nicht die
Zeit streiten momentan zu haben wir
müssen Verein sein der Staat Israel ist
im Krieg es wir ke einach K sein und es
wird auch keine kurze Krieg sein viele
Schlussfolgerungen die wir seit Jahren
nicht mehr gesehen haben und das kann
sogar eine überregional werden
überregionale Krieg sein ich habe gerade
Ministerpräsident nah getroffen und ich
habe ihm gezeigt gesagt dass ich bereit
bin momentan mit ihm
zusammen ein notstandregierung gerade zu
gründen und alle Streitigkeiten Z Seite
zu
tun
uns haben weiß dass momentan das
Kabinett nicht wirklich funktioniert und
so können wir keinen Krieg führen der
Staat Israel muss eine
fachliche Kraft auch in eine
notstandregierung haben und es ist gut
dass der Herr ganz auch das mitmachen
würden wenn wir eineierung haben dann
werden unsere Feinde verstehen dass wir
gemeinsam sind und unsere Feinde W Dasch
en können und das Volk Israel wird vin
sein und wird eine Antwort geben
gegenüber diesen Drohung wir habe einen
harten Schlag bekommen wir sind sehr
verärgert es ist ein großes Schmerz für
uns aber so führt man keine Kriege
sondern muss man das mit unter kühlen
Gefühl führen und wir müssen keine
Politik oder kleine Politik momentan
machen sondern eine richtige Linie
treffen
und wir müsen nicht and bis wir komplett
ein Sieg
haben Professor frölich wäre eine
Einheitsregierung eine
einheitsfrontregierung in Israel eine
realistische Option und würde das
vielleicht den den Einfluss der
religiösen und nationalistischen
harliner etwas begrenzen aber ihn
begrenzen würde in der jetzigen
Situation ist schwer zu sagen also sie
werden natürlich wenn Sie eine solche
not Regierung bilden auch in irgendeiner
Form in ihrer Rhetorik vielleicht ein
Stück weit zurückschrauben müssen aber
feststeht das steht jetzt auch alles
hinten an das ist nicht das Thema das
Thema ist im Moment die Sicherheit und
Existenz Israels die bedroht ist und da
rückt man zusammen ob Oppositionelle und
ungeachtet der Tatsache dass dieses Land
im Moment natürlich auch polarisierter
ist denn je insofern ist das
auch war geht auch dieses strategische
Kalkül wenn es denn eins war der has
natürlich überhaupt nicht nicht auf der
Schuss ist eher nach hinten losgegangen
es stärkt die jetzige Regierung
Rechtsregierung von
Netanyahu in dieser Situation ich ich
würde trotzdem zum Ende unseres
Gesprächs gerne noch ein Funken Hoffnung
auf Frieden da einbringen so eine
Regierung der nationalen Einheit wo
Opposition und Regierung
zusammenarbeiten die könnte unter
Umständen Dinge tun die eine nur linke
oder nur Rechte Regierung nicht machen
kann nämlich echte Schritte auf die
Palästinenser Richtung Frieden keine
Frage die Hoffnung ist immer da ich habe
wenig Hoffnung muss ich wirklich sagen
im Moment dass es dazu kommen könnte
allerdings ist es nicht unberechtigt zu
sagen in einer solchen Situation was
wissen wir was das für eine Eigendynamik
entwickelt hängt auch sehr davon ab wie
lange dieser Krieg dieser dieser
Konflikt jetzt andauert
oder bzw wie schnell er gelöst werden
kann
also ich bin nicht allzu optimistisch
aber ich teile Ihre Einschätzung
natürlich keimt auch in einer solchen
Übergangsregierung einer
Notstandsregierung ein Stück weit
Hoffnung dass die Parteien sich und die
Antagonisten auch in Israel sich ein
Stück annähern und sich des Problems
auch vielleicht in einer anderen Form
annehmen bei netania habe ich wenig
Hoffnung im Moment allerdings Israel das
gehört mir dazu die Selbstkritik wird
kommen israel hat das in den letzten
Jahren mit seiner Politik natürlich
durchaus auch forziert die die Ohnmacht
der Palästinenser insbesondere der Hamas
im Gazastreifen der Situation dort
herzlichen Dank Professor Stefan
fröhlich und vielen Dank dafür dass sie
zumindest ein kleines FL Flämmchen
Hoffnung noch am Leben gehalten haben
danke schön auch die Bundesregierung hat
sich in diesem Konflikt eindeutig auf
die Seite Israels gestellt und
verurteilte die Angriffe der Hamas als
terroristischen Akt Außenministerin
berbur und anschließend innen Ministerin
Feser heute morgen hat die Hamas in
einem unbekannten Ausmaß den Terror über
Israel gebracht an einem Feiertag
wachten die Menschen in Israel in Angst
und Schrecken auf noch ist unklar wie
viele hunderte unschuldige dieser Terror
heute aus dem Leben gerissen hat denn
die Angriffe und die Gewalt der Hammers
dauern an aber schon jetzt ist klar
dieser Tag ist eine zesur ein
präsidenloser Akt der Eskalation durch
die
Hamas das Vorgehen der Hamas ist durch
nichts zu
rechtfertigen nichts rechtfertigt
unterschiedslosen
Raketenbeschuss kommandoangriffe auf
friedliche
Zivilisten die brutale Entführung von
unschuldigen
Menschen wenn man sich diese furchtbaren
Videos von den den brutalen Entführungen
anschaut die über soziale Medien
verbreitet werden dann stockt einem der
Atem angsterfüllte Gesichter von völlig
unbeteiligten von älteren Menschen von
Frauen von einer Mutter mit ihren zwei
Kindern die offensichtlich durch
hamaskämpfer entführt worden
sind diese geiselname durch die Hamas
sind abscheulich und verstoßen gegen das
re
Völkerrecht der Terror der Hamas muss
sofort
aufhören die deutsche Bundesregierung
steht solidarisch an der Seite
Israels israel hat das völkerrechtlich
verbriefte Recht sich gegen diesen
perfiden Terror zu
verteidigen die Eskalation der Gewalt
durch die Hamas zeigt einmal mehr nur
eine politische Lösung kann den Menschen
in Israel wie auch den palästinensischen
Menschen ein Leben in Frieden und würde
bringen der Terror der Hamas hat die
Region einmal mehr weiter vom Frieden
entfernt durch diese Terrorangriffe
besteht nun die
unkalkulierbare Gefahr einer großen
regionalen
Eskalation ich kann nur auf das
Schärfste davor warnen dass sich andere
diesem Terror
anschließen ich habe heute mit
unterschiedlichsten Partnern in der
Region telefoniert und unseren
israelischen Freunden habe ich unsere
ganze Solidarität
versichert heute ist dem Auswärtigen Amt
der Krisenstab der Bundesregierung
zusammengekommen wir beobachten die Lage
weiter sehr genau zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
raten wir dringend von Reisen nach nach
Israel und in die palästinensischen
Gebiete
ab alle deutschen Staatsangehörige
Vorort bitte ich dringend sich in die
krisenliste das sogenannte Elephant
System
einzutragen herzlichen Dank also erstmal
will ich noch mal sagen dass die
furchtbar terroristischen Anschläge der
herras durch nichts zu rechtfertigen
sind und aufs tiefste zu verurteilen
sind wir stehen fest an der Seite als
Bundesrepublik Israels und der Menschen
in Israel und wir kümmern uns auch darum
dass in Hessen die jüdischen Einrichtung
jetzt besonderen Schutz bekommen ich
habe heute mit der IMK vorsitzendin
ihres Spranger schon darüber telefoniert
jetzt zur Stunde tauschen sich die
Länder noch einmal darüber aus ich finde
es ganz wichtig dass wir jetzt an der
Seite unserer jüdischen Freundinen und
Freunde
stehen zugeschaltet aus Israel ist jetzt
Christoph kleemmann Christoph kleemmann
ist der Leiter des Büros der FDP nahen
Friedrich Naumann Stiftung in Israel
guten Tag wie wie beurteilen Sie die
Situation in Israel und
Gaza ja die Lage ist weiterhin
unübersichtlich gerade im Süden des
Landes wo ja diese Terroristen über die
Grenze gekommen sind
kommt es weiterhin zu kämpfen
die israelischen streitkämpfe versuchen
die Terroristen
zu stellen Geisel zu befreien aber es
kommt immer auch wieder zu neuen
Infiltrationen über die Grenze ähm
gerade kam Berichte rein dass ein ein
kleiner Grenzort ein kibuz angegriffen
worden ist von
hamaskämpfern und die israelischen
Streitkräfte versuchen jetzt dort
reinzugehen versuchen die Geisel zu
befreien und versuchen die Terroristen
auszuschalten und gleichzeitig kommt es
immer wieder auch zu Luftangriffen auf
die logistische und militärische
Infrastruktur der Hamas im Gazastreifen
jetzt hat premier in dero angekündigt
eine extreme Reaktion auf die Angriffe
der Hamas rechnen Sie damit
dass Israel den Gazastreifen militärisch
angreift und besetzt vielleicht auf
Dauer
besetzt ich glaube das ist noch zu früh
darüber zu spekulieren ähm der Zeit
verfolgt verfolgt Israel ähm drei
Strategien zum einen wie gesagt im im
Süden die Lage unter die Kontrolle zu
bekommen und erneute Infiltrationen zu
verhindern ähm äh und als zweites wurden
jetzt schon über 80.000 Reservisten
eingezogen also man geht auch von einem
größeren Konflikt aus und auch das
deutet darauf hin dass es zu einer
größeren Bodenoffensive kommen wird und
der dritte Punkt ist dass die Israel
israelische Regierung auch im Norden
also an der Grenze zum Libanon ähm ihre
Truppen zusammenziehen dannn auch dort
rechnet man gegebenenfalls zumindest äh
zu Angriffen ähm und dort wird auch äh
das Militär und die Reservisten äh
verstärkt und zusammengezogen und äh
sozusagen als Abschreckung gegen weitere
auch Angriffe von der terroristischen
hisbolla im Norden äh sich zu schützen
jetzt folgt also auf die Gewalt der
heramas eine Eskalation der Gewalt durch
die israelische Armee gibt es irgendeine
Chance dieses Spirale der Gewalt zu
durchbrechen ja also ich würde erstmal
sagen dass das äh jetzt keine Gewalt der
israelischen Regierung ist sondern es
ist eine Reaktion auf einen
terroristischen Anschlag ähm und israel
hat das Selbstverteidigungsrecht und
muss davon auch Gebrauch machen um seine
eigene
Zivilbevölkerung zu schützen und ich
denke dass die israelische Regierung
dort
entsprechend vorgehen wird
ich wie gesagt gehe davon aus dass es zu
einer größeren Bodenoffensive kommen
wird wenn man sich die Zahlen der
Reservisten an anschaut
aber das ist halt eine angemessene
Reaktion auf das was gestern passiert
ist denn man darf ja nicht vergessen das
ist wirklich ein ein einen Schockmoment
für die israelische Gesellschaft noch
nie wurden so viele Zivilisten an einem
Tag brutal ermordet und darauf muss die
israelische Regierung auch reagieren
jetzt gibt es ja Gespräche zur Bildung
einer
Einheitsregierung in Israel halten Sie
das für realistisch und sehen sie darin
eine
Chance ja also gestern gab es bereits
Gespräche zwischen Netanyahu und den
beiden
Oppositionsführern auf der einen Seite
den Liberalen Lapid und auf der anderen
Seite Benny ganz lapit hat ganz klar
gemacht dass er eine solche Regierung
nur eintreten würde sollten die beiden
rechten ultranationalen Parteien nicht
Teil einer solchen Einheitsregierung
sein
wenn das wenn nanyahu dem zustimmt dann
sehe ich dass es zu einer solchen
Einheitsregierung kommen kann kommen
muss ich glaube es wäre auch ein gutes
Signal wenn diese rechtsnationalen
Parteien aus der aktuellen Regierung
entfernt werden und wenn es zu einer
Einheitsregierung kommt die dann maßvoll
die Reaktionen der israelischen
Regierung orchestriert ich stelle ihn
jetzt noch zum Abschluss die Frage die
ich soeben auch Professor fröhlich
gestellt habe wenn es da eine Regierung
der Einheit in Israel gibt die keine
Opposition fürchten muss hätte diese
Regierung der Einheit die Chance
Schritte auf die Palästinenser zuzugehen
um vielleicht wirklich einem Frieden
etwas näher zu kommen als wir das in den
letzten 50 Jahren erlebt
haben also ich glaube da muss man
realistisch bleiben ich glaube eine
solche
Einheitsregierung ist vor allen dazu da
in diesem Kriegszustand in den sich
Israel jetzt befindet die richtigen
Entscheidungen zu treffen auf einem
breiten Konsens m ich denke nicht davon
aus dass sich solche eine solche
Regierung dann über den Krieg hinaus äh
weiter halten lässt sondern dann denke
ich würde es eher zu Neuwahlen kommen
oder zu einer anderen Verschiebung
innerhalb der Koalition
also dass jetzt sozusagen eine
Einheitsregierung in dem AK in der
aktuellen Lage im
Kriegszustand auch diese große Frage des
Friedens mit den Palästinenser angehen
wird davon gehe ich nicht aus das war
die Einschätzung von Christoph kleemmann
Leiter des Büros der Friedrich Naumann
Stiftung in Israel herzlichen Dank liebe
Zuschauer Liebe
liebe Zuschauer liebe Zuschauer das war
unsere Sondersendung zur kriegerischen
Situation in Israel und Gaza ich darf
sie drauf aufmerksam machen ab 17 Uhr
unsere Sendung zur Wahl in Bayern und im
Hessen im Studio begrüßt Sie hier Eva
Lindenau schalten sie rein spannender
Wahlabend heute und jetzt machen wir
weiter mit ihrer unserem Phönix plus zur
Situation in Polen
[Musik]
in Bayern und